The president of
the United States never technically takes
a day off.
Even when they’re ostensibly “on vacation”
they are still very much the leader of the
country and have many duties to fulfill on
a daily basis.
For example, even while on vacation, they
need to continue to have things like intelligence
and national security briefings and other
such meetings so that if an emergency does
suddenly come up, they can react quickly in
an informed way.
Because of this, the president, in addition
to never technically being able to have a
full day off while on vacation, doesn’t
get sick days either.
Of course, the president is not only human
but also generally speaking a quite old human,
and thus they get ill, occasionally seriously.
So what happens then?
This is where the 25th Amendment potentially
comes into effect.
In a nutshell, among other things, it provides
that if the president ever gets so ill that
they cannot physically perform necessary presidential
duties anymore, their vice president can become
the “Acting President” on their behalf
until they’re able to resume their duties.
So, in a way, this is a mechanism for the
president to take a sick day if they want
it and whenever they want it.
It’s also noteworthy that even if the president
does not wish to relinquish the office during
a time when they are “unable to discharge
the powers and duties of his office”, the
25th Amendment provides a mechanism for the
vice president to simply take the office from
the president until such time as the president
is once again able to resume duties.
(Amusingly, it’s not fully clear here what
the scope of this section of the 25th Amendment
is.
For example, while the president is sleeping,
and thus in an unconscious state, they are
most definitely “unable to discharge the
powers and duties of [the] office” until
someone wakes them up.
So technically the vice president and certain
others could get together on any given night
and temporarily make the vice president acting
president until such time as the president
wakes up and no doubt sends off the appropriate
document to declare that they are, in fact,
fit for duty, with Congress no doubt concurring
at that point…
Or, if I were president and my VP did that,
I’d probably just take that rare opportunity
to roll back over and sleep in for once, then
maybe around noon have a leisurely breakfast
before finally sending off the appropriate
letter that I’m back in business.)
In the end, this latter rule allowing the
vice president to forcibly take over is probably
for the best as United States presidents are
generally loath to give up the office, even
temporarily.
Despite many, many presidents having serious
health issues and occasionally being incapacitated
during their time in office (generally largely
kept from the public eye at the time), only
two have actually used this power in the over
half a century since the 25th Amendment was
ratified.
Breaking the trend, the first president to
make use of the 25th Amendment was Ronald
Reagan on July 13, 1985 when he temporarily
officially bestowed the powers of the office
onto Vice President George Bush while Reagan
underwent surgery for colon cancer.
Bush reportedly spent a whole 8 hours being
president before Reagan decided he’d recovered
enough from his surgery to start being president
again.
A thing to note is that prior to handing off
the powers of the presidency to Bush at 11:28AM,
Reagan spent his morning as he normally did,
going about presidential duties, and subsequently
spent most of the evening after he became
president again at 7:22PM catching up on everything
he’d missed during the day.
So not really much of a sick day.
The only other president to bestow the powers
of the presidency on their vice president
was George W. Bush in 2002 and later in 2007,
each time so that he could have a colonoscopy.
On each occasion, Vice President Dick Cheney
was acting president for a little over 2 hours
at which point Bush resumed his duties.
Or to put it another way, during his 8 years
in office, Bush technically had four hours
of official time off, most of which he spent
with a camera up his butt…
(It’s good to be the president?)
This lack of leave taken for ill health is
a surprising fact given, as previously alluded
to, the large percentage of presidents who
have suffered through various serious illnesses
during their time in office.
Most infamously, Woodrow Wilson had a massive
stroke in 1919 resulting in the temporary
loss of use of the left side of his body,
as well as him becoming blind in the left
eye and with diminished vision in his right.
What his cognitive state was at this time
isn’t fully known, as this was all kept
from the public by his wife, Edith, and his
physician, Dr. Cary Grayson.
So how was he able to run the country in this
state?
Well, he wasn’t really.
His wife took over handling what information
was passed to him and what issues she simply
delegated out for other people to handle.
She also barred any direct access to the president
for several weeks after the stroke, with the
lone exception being that Dr. Grayson was
allowed to attend him (and we’re speculating
nurses, though this is never mentioned anywhere
we could find).
As Edith herself would later write,
So began my stewardship, I studied every paper,
sent from the different Secretaries or Senators,
and tried to digest and present in tabloid
form the things that, despite my vigilance,
had to go to the President.
I, myself, never made a single decision regarding
the disposition of public affairs.
The only decision that was mine was what was
important and what was not, and the very important
decision of when to present matters to my
husband.
That said, it is thought by many historians
that her claim that she never made direct
presidential decisions herself is at best
stretching the truth and at worst a blatant
lie.
That’s not to mention completely controlling
the information that went to the president
and what tasks (and to whom) were delegated
out is questionable for a person not elected
to office to do, even for a day, let alone
an extended period.
While Wilson did recover somewhat over the
next year and a half or so of his presidency,
in the interim there was much question over
whether he was actually still mentally and
physically fit enough to continue on as president.
Despite this and certain very pressing and
far reaching matters being decided, like whether
the United States should join the League of
Nations, he refused to give up his position-
a key point discussed when the 25th Amendment
was being drafted a few decades later.
While other presidents had before and after
Wilson suffered from various ailments, most
notable to the development of the 25th Amendment
was Dwight D. Eisenhower.
While in office, he suffered a severe heart
attack and then a subsequent stroke.
He also had to have surgery to remove about
ten inches of his small intestine as a result
of complications owing to Crohn’s disease.
During these times, he did attempt to take
sick days by having Attorney General Herbert
Brownell Jr write up a document passing off
some of the powers and duties of the president
to Vice President Richard Nixon.
Other presidents had more or less done similar
things before when necessary, but always in
secret, so as not to publicly reveal their
medical issues.
Eisenhower was essentially bucking the trend
of keeping it secret and trying to set a precedent
to make the whole thing official.
And, indeed, from a practical standpoint,
Nixon and Eisenhower’s cabinet did take
over his duties when he was incapacitated.
It also could be interpreted that Article
II, Section 1, Clause 6 of the U.S. Constitution
did allow for such when the president was
unable “to discharge the powers and duties
of the… office”.
But the wording here is sufficiently vague
to call into question whether in these cases
the vice president is actually endowed with
the powers given to the president.
Because of this, despite Eisenhower giving
the green light, there was uncertainty whether
Nixon was actually the acting president or
not at these times, which could have created
major problems had certain emergencies come
up.
The matter finally came to a head with a president
most considered the picture of robust, youthful,
health- John F. Kennedy.
It turns out, Kennedy essentially needed his
own pharmacy and team of doctors to keep him
functioning semi-normally throughout his presidency-
a fact only quite recently made publicly known.
The medical issues Kennedy suffered from were
many and serious (some of which may in turn
have been caused by the extensive medication
he regularly took).
First up was a potentially life threatening
problem in Addison’s disease, where the
adrenal glands don’t produce enough of certain
essential hormones.
Next he suffered from osteoporosis resulting
in three fractured vertebrae in his back.
He also suffered from irritable bowel syndrome
that saw him dealing with severe abdominal
pain and occasional dangerous bouts of diarrhea.
Then there was his hypothyroidism.
And, just for fun, likely because of some
of the medications he was on, he seemed particularly
prone to infections.
To treat all this, he was variously put on
thyroid hormone, Ritalin, methadone, Demerol,
barbiturates (such as phenobarbital), various
antidiarrheal drugs, testosterone, procaine,
codeine, corticosteroids, Lomotil, Metamucil,
paregoric, amphetamines, meprobamate, Librium,
and given penicillin and various other antibiotics
whenever infections would spring up…
Notably, many of these medications could potentially
effect mood and his decision making ability.
But without some of them, Kennedy would have
been crippled by pain.
Even with them, as Kennedy’s political advisor,
Dave Powers, once noted, Kennedy always traveled
“with crutches”.
Further, when he was out of the public eye,
he walked
gritting his teeth…but then when he came
into the room where the crowd was gathered,
he was erect and smiling, looking as fit and
healthy as the light-heavyweight champion
of the world.
Then after he finished his speech and answered
questions from the floor and shook hands with
everyone, we would help him into the car and
he would lean back on the seat and close his
eyes in pain.
Kennedy’s many maladies were not, however,
what helped spur the creation of the 25th
Amendment, though may have been had they been
widely known.
Rather, it was when Kennedy was shot that
everything finally came to a head, with the
question being asked, “What would have happened
had Kennedy lived, but been in a brain-dead
state?”
As previously noted, while one could interpret
Article II, Section 1, Clause 6 of the Constitution
in such a way as to provide for the vice president
to take over almost immediately in such cases,
the wording wasn’t concrete enough on this
or for many other such scenarios in which
the vice president might need to become Acting
President.
It wasn’t even clear in these cases if the
vice president did take over if the original
president should get the job back if they
were once again fit for office later during
the allotted term.
This ambiguity is a major issue if, say, a
nuclear strike was launched against the United
States in the interim from when the president
was no longer fit for office and when the
government finally got around to deciding
the vice president should indeed take over.
Thus, about a year and a half after Kennedy’s
assassination, in July of 1965, congress sent
the 25th Amendment out to the states to ratify,
which it finally was on February 10, 1967,
clarifying what should be done in many of
these scenarios.
So to sum up, the president is not given any
allotment of sick days, but the 25th Amendment
does provide them a mechanism to take such
if they feel like they’re unable to perform
the duties of the office.
But, for reasons like that it’s not politically
couth for the president to show any weakness,
only two presidents in history have ever done
this since it became an option- both of whom
were having something done to their colon
at the time…
For the rest, when they were medically incapacitated,
they seem to generally try to hide this from
the public whenever possible and to delegate
tasks and rearrange their work schedule as
best they could to take a little time off.
And, where they couldn’t do such, they simply
muscled through the rest of their duties.